[Music]
Loesser oh so you'd like my business
card you'd like to network with me don't
touch this first oh my goodness it's
gone now it's back that amazing so it so
anyway my name is crystal sense key
wired contributor I'm going to show you
how to vanish your business card if the
economy doesn't do that for you anyway
it's just with a wave it's magically
gone all I'm doing is a little stage
thing called back palming and so the
card is being pivoted onto the back of
my fingers curved like so and any
discrepancies here are covered by the
fact that I'm waving my hand like a
maniac boom you produce it so I'll show
you the details of this basically you
can start with in the palm of your hand
with your thumb on the top or you can
start with it at your fingertips it
doesn't matter either way you're going
to bring it down to your fingertips and
a curl in your middle and ring fingers
okay on the back and then grip out with
your pointer and pinky fingers and then
you're just going to clip the card
simultaneously between the top chunk in
the bottom chunk as you spread open your
hand I mean it's not really that
complicated once you're in this position
um if you spread out your hands then
naturally the card will Bend back there
then to produce it you just reverse the
move it's the same thing in Reverse so
one more time
curl in your middle two fingers like so
grip with these guys straighten out keep
waving and then when you produce it you
can you're just reversing it and
grabbing it with your thumb you can kind
of you can just wave produce it like
that or you can just sort of pretend
like you're plucking it from midair
you're just grabbing it out of this
window or something which is just kind
of a jut forward and then pull back so
you know maybe that'll bring your resume
to the top of the stack here's my
business card
hired me I'm
sprit and cooked pretty soon so anyway
that was how to vanish your business
card